well welcome back others rage to
catholic i believe in god i even say the
odd hail mary but i'm bucking a trend
according to a new poll 81 percent of
americans believe in god but that's the
lowest it's ever been in the u.s in
australia it's now less than half 48 in
the uk less than a third so they believe
in any god at all well in a moment i was
speaking to franklin graham one of
america's most controversial evangelists
he's the son of famous preacher billy
graham who was one of the most important
christian leaders of the 20th century he
was a pastor to presidents and met them
all from truman to trump
franklin's continuing his father's
legacy spreading the word right the way
to the white house but he's also been
heavily criticized for controversial
views on subjects like homosexuality and
frankly graham joyce vanessa good to see
you franklin good to see you you're here
on a uk tour
we're playing at the eight we're playing
i think it's like a rock star you're
playing the excel in london on saturday
so obviously a lot of support for you
when you do these big events before we
get into talk to you about your reaction
just quickly to this story of the
ten-year-old girl who had to cross state
lines to have a legal abortion well it's
sad appears not my my heart goes out to
the family to this young girl they have
to make the decision it's not a question
of whether she has to go across state
lines or down the street like going to a
barber shop
the question is this decision of having
an abortion is a very difficult decision
and so and i understand the family and
understand
they're they're wanting to have an
abortion understand that and if it was
my daughter uh if this would be a very
tough decision so i just pray that god
would you if it was your daughter would
you let her have an abortion if an
illegal immigrant and raped her and
impregnated her it appears i can't
answer that uh uh why not well because i
don't know right now i don't know it's
it's just you have to be faced with that
really because i know immediately i have
a ten-year-old daughter i know
immediately the answer is absolutely i
would i would do whatever i could it's a
very tough decision pierce isn't that
tough
of course it's a 10 year old girl
raped by an illegal immigrant and you
make her carry the baby but it's no it's
the decision between the parents and the
nice girl you don't know what you would
do what i'm saying is the decision of
the parents and that's what if it was
you
you're saying you don't know what you'd
do well i i have i mean i would be torn
be honest with you what do you think
you'd do
i i'd be i don't know until i was faced
with that but i wouldn't be putting in a
hypothetical we know this has just
happened this has happened to this young
girl and it's it's it's sad that it has
happened and my prayers are with her
and her family at this time talking a
prayer what is going on with religion
around the world why is it going slowly
out of fashion well it's not a question
to be into fashion uh pierce and it's
not a question whether you believe in
god or not the question is do you have a
relationship with god's son jesus christ
and jesus christ came to this earth to
die for our sins and he took our sins to
the cross and he shed his blood on a
cross for our sins and it's up to us to
uh turn from our sins and accept jesus
christ by faith and if we're willing to
do that god will forgive us
and he will extend to us okay one of the
issues i think is this you're a very
influential man in the christian world
but you know that you've got into a lot
of hot water over comments you've made
for example about homosexuality right
which you believe is a sin right well
it's what god says what do you believe
well that's what the bible teaches well
the bible says all sorts of things which
we don't do now no i believe the bible
from cover to cover appears i don't
understand but i believe the bible has
stuff in it which would be absurd no i'm
sorry i believe the bible to be the word
of god so we should still be stoning
people in the street uh
i've seen i believe the the bible
covered a cover and in the old testament
in there they talked you know about
stoning people to death on the street
would you do that in the old testament
they did
jesus
straighten that up
and when they brought a woman who had
been caught in adultery and they brought
her before jesus to stone him
and he wrote in the sand we don't know
what he wrote but i think he wrote the
sense of all those that were wanting to
stone her i think he wrote those on the
ground
and they slowly disappeared and finally
they were all gone and jesus asked where
are your accusers he said lord i have
none then he told her go and sin no more
and that's the way jesus dealt with it
you your tour is called god loves you
yes why
do you think it's christian to
stigmatize gay people well i don't
stigmatize them well you say that
they're sinners but we're all sinners
you
and me but you know that those comments
have gone down very badly you've had
four dates before have had to be
cancelled because of protests and so on
i believe in free speech you're
perfectly entitled to your views and i
understand that driven by religious
conviction but are your views about
homosexuals are they changing at all no
i mean the fact is god loves the
homosexual people he loves all of us but
if we come to god we have to repent do
you love homosexuals sure and i love
them enough to want to warn them and
tell them why are they more sinful than
you they're not more sinful what about
their sexuality
what i'm saying they're not more sinful
than me or you
the point is all of us are born into sin
peers you were born into sin your mother
when she brought you into this world uh
she brought you in a sinful world and
christ came to take our sins and he died
on that cross for our sins and for us to
be forgiven we have to come to god
return from a man like me having sex
with my wife and we're both straight
people
that is not sinful right
well god designed marriage
but if i was gay in having sex with a
man
you would think that's sinful it's not
that i would think that it's it's that's
what god understands that's what you
think no it's what god teaches do you
believe it
it's what the bible teaches right here's
my problem this is why i think religion
is going about a fashion with younger
people is they see someone like you
hugely influential and they think well
how to say
who's he
actually to say that gay people are
sinners and straight people
are not no it's not straight people or
incentives straight people are about
their sexuality and who they choose to
have sex with specifically they're still
sinners
i'm not sinning if i'm having sex with
my wife right no but you're a sinner but
if a gay man is having sex with his with
his gay husband this this you don't
believe in either right
i mean
you know that you've got into big
trouble over there no it appears i i
don't believe i'm in trouble over it
well you haven't you've had you've had
tall dates canceled i'm giving the
opportunity to try and explain why a god
loves you tall can't extend to loving
gay people right right to love each
other and to have sex with each other if
they if they god god made us male and
female
and he designed sex between to be
between a man and a woman and not
between two women not two men that's the
way god made us and created us and it's
just the way it is what if what if
they're gay and they feel that they want
to have sex with people
like them well it's i'm just saying it's
the bible calls it sin and i'll care
enough about it by the bible it's you as
well call it sin right my point is i
know lots of gay people who are far less
sinful in my estimation than lots of
straight people i know sure
and i don't understand why i should be
free and you should be free to have sex
with who we like but gay people come no
you don't have sex with whoever you like
it's between a marriage relationship
between a man and a woman and that's the
way god designs do you understand why
gay people and people who have no issue
with gay people feel so strongly about
the comments you've said well first of
all i i don't hate gay people and i
don't preach against gay people and i
don't go demonstrate against gay people
you'll never see where i've said
anything bad about the gay people i just
you just have you just don't realize no
i i believe you just said it's fine for
straight people
to have sex with each other but can i
know but can i not have the views that i
believe god wants us to you're entitled
to your view no frankly you are entitled
to your view and that's why i'm excited
to say that i think one of the reasons
religion is becoming less popular it's
because people look at senior christian
figures like you and think well that
doesn't sound very christian to me
that sounds to me like somebody who is
homophobic but the churches in this in
this country in the uk that are growing
and that are expanding are churches that
teach the bible
those are the churches that are growing
the churches that have turned their back
on the scripture that have compromised
the truth of the scripture those
churches are dying i think franklin you
should just think about this a bit more
times are changing people are changing
god's no longer gay people no longer
have to hide god doesn't change you
yesterday today actually we've moved on
so much from large sways of the bible we
have you know it and i have it but good
to see you good to see you thank you